things in the agenda okay
okay we are a live chat thank you very
much fabiola and welcome to the start
joint committee meeting
uh of wednesday the 24th of march 2021
which sounds like a a made-up date but
it has gone all that fast um
we've got a lot on the agenda today to
take us through i know we're still
waiting on a couple of
um officers from rochester to join us so
hopefully they'll join us
uh in the meanwhile in terms of
attendance i've got apologies from tom
wilkinson from tame side there any
others that we need to note
wednesday 24th march 2021
okay bear with me because there is
seems that we've got a little lag i can
hear myself repeating back
um someone's watching it already
thousands okay so it should be okay now
this um technical issue resolved
um thank you thanks fabiola
in terms of attendances then are we any
more apologies to note uh
no other apologies to the future okay
thank you
uh item twos the minutes uh at the
previous meeting held in 2020
which was years ago agreed thank you
council mcgee
are we happy to agree those i'm seeing
nods around the room
thank you declarations of interest if
members can give any in the usual way
um either now or let us know within a
timely manner at the end of the meeting
that would be great
and we'll go on to item four which is a
quarter three
uh performance and proposed measures
which i believe nickel is going to take
us through nicola
thank you chair i will just share my
screen so you can see
i'm going to start with the appendix to
the report which sets out
our achievements in quarter three just
starting first of all with commercial
with the savings
and we have a target of 5.6 million and
as at quarter three
um we're at 5.8 million um
3.3 million of that is yet to be
ratified by our finance colleagues
um so that figure may change slightly so
it may come down
but also we've got quarter four still to
come as well
so we are now confident that we will
achieve this target for this year
that means that the return on investment
target of two times
return is now at 3.6 which is a
fantastic result
and moving over to income i think as we
discussed at the last joint committee
and particularly in quarters one and two
we did very much struggle with our
income target because of
all the reasons that we know um but
we it has picked up in quarter three and
in quarter four
and we're still um unsure whether we
will achieve that target this financial
year will be closer than
we anticipated last time we reported to
you and we have achieved a couple of new
commissions including one for manchester
council
as well so moving over then to
communities our social value target is
25 and i'm pleased to report that
quarter 3 we're up to 27
which is great the local spend figure
this
does sort of fluctuate as you can see on
a monthly basis because it does depend
on what invoices
come through at each particular month
but the target is
50 and we are now above that target at
just over 52
overall
finally just in terms of compliance um
we have a target of 90
for this and again a bit like with the
local spend it does fluctuate on a
monthly basis
but as you can see we are on an upward
trajectory and we are
um having a big push during quarter four
to ensure that we achieve that target of
90 percent are there any questions on
the quarter three
results before i move on to the rest of
the paper
thanks for that nicola i'm not seeing
any hands up oh cancer mcgee
thank you so um three very short points
so uh i think income
given that it's 80 from a basically six
months
um uh possibility that's very good given
that we didn't get anything much in the
first two quarters
i think the ratified savings uh you know
again um quite um quite remarkable given
everything that's gone on
and um i think the rest in terms of
social value
um i know it's something that i i don't
know about everybody else but i know
it's one of the things that we
we're looking at all the time to see
what measures we can do and how
uh and how we can improve you know
locally our commissioning
to to uh to ratify that so i think
overall
given and i think i'm basically
repeating what i said in december
uh uh which is given where we started
from and what's happened
and how long it took us to get going i
think this is a really good set of uh
set figures thank you for that
uh councilman anybody else want to
come in there not seeing any other hands
up no i'd echo those comments actually i
think as you say
it's all caveated with it's been a
difficult year because of kovid but
actually
um the figures speak to themselves don't
they and that we've still managed to be
really impressive
uh and we're above target on um
our um generated savings
um income is not where we'd like it to
be but i think given that it's
you know only a small proportion off
really um
we're very lucky and actually in terms
of the amount of local spend that we
still
we still create we should we should
welcome that as well so yeah i entirely
agree i think it's really impressive
especially given the state of the world
that we're in but impressive nonetheless
um thank you very much nicholas you want
to carry on thank you chair
um i will just share now the reports
there it is
so the second part of this report is the
proposed measures for
the the next financial year so each year
we do review these and
strive to do continuous improvement
through stretched targets
however as we've just talked about it's
been a difficult year and
meant some uncertainty about what we
might be able to achieve over the next
12 months
so we propose for this next 12 months
that majority of the targets remain the
same
the only one that we're proposing to
change is the in-year
income target um and we propose that
you'll
get a better picture of this in the
budget report that's in the
um second part of the agenda today um
but it's just to
um ensure that the income target
reflects what's in the
budget for the next financial year
rather than just this historic
150 k that we've had to date
so the rest of the targets remain the
same savings of 5.6
10 investment 2 social value 25
locals spend 50 and verified spend at 90
percent
thank you nicola sensible and pragmatic
i think
yeah i i i wouldn't necessarily disagree
with you councilman
i suppose when i went through this my
question was on the income
stuff is that you've always kind of
aside from this year
um going over and above your targets
anyway and i think we have quite a good
culture here of
looking at targets and then also aiming
for the horizon which is really good
um i wouldn't want that to end and i
wouldn't want you to feel like you're
being set up to fail in terms of the
targets i think obviously
it's good to make sure that you you sort
of work out a balanced position
but you do that historically anyway so
i'm not sure that necessarily making a
target that
is sort of inflated necessarily
helps you do any better in terms of your
targets
um or so it makes you work any
differently
so i sort of looked at this now i kind
of thought it was a bit it was a little
bit of a pointless sort of book exercise
was my view
i don't know if anybody else wants to
come in might be wrong but lorraine or
nicola do you want to
talk about it yes
sharon i'm happy to respond to that um
it certainly isn't pointless um it
really
will be um a method to obviously pushes
and challenges harder and
i think you point and that you make
about will it make us work differently
or harder or better probably not because
i think
you can see the commitment and the
approach that we take
and have taken year on year we've always
you know
well and truly exceeded the income
target and this year has been
challenging but we we know already
that when we report quarter 42 we're
going to be very very close to
hitting that target without sharing
quarter four with you at the 43 meeting
so we're not far off track even through
a year that's been particularly
challenging
we also know um already and here we are
on the 24th of march that we've secured
a couple of um commissions one quite
substantial
which again i'll say for the quarter
four meeting and
so i think that the ambition for us to
do as
as we've suggested today is is realistic
um and we're optimistic and we will do
our best as always to keep
that flag flying and i think because the
year has been so challenging i think
our usual motivation will be that we
will work even harder during 21-22 to
make sure we hit that
of course thanks lorraine i'd expect so
uh and i think that's what we'd all come
to expect given the
sort of history of some of this okay
well that that's that's fine by me
there's anybody
else have any questions comments on this
council ross
thank you chad um yeah i agree with um
with what lorraine says i think it is it
is good to
um to be ambitious uh for the year ahead
but i think we need to be mindful
as as members of this committee that
we're still not out of the woods yet
with regards to
to cover so when we come to look at
reviewing things
later on next year hopefully you know
targets will be met surpassed but for us
as us as committee members we need to be
mindful that it's been a very very
difficult year and we're nowhere near
out of it
yet in terms of the the the things that
we have to face so
um yeah no thanks for that thank you
council russ casa mcgee
i think the point about not being out of
the woods is well made because
i know and i know each authority is
different um
um but i think we're looking at this
coming year
and i'm sure we're not alone um with
slightly more trepidation than
we went through the pla the last year
because
um uh government were generous in the
you know to some degree in their grants
and that made us
the ability to to offset losses of
income and we've um
and we've amortized some losses of uh
council taxes everybody's done over a
number of years
i have a feeling that next year this
next financial year will be harder
and if that's the case for us that could
be the case notwithstanding that you've
got some
new commissions lorraine but that could
be that could be the case for others as
well
and it may well be that people make sort
of delaying decisions rather than
cancelling decisions and
that may affect where we're going which
is why i thought uh
my my shorthand at the beginning
sensible and pragmatic was trying to
reflect all of that in my head
no absolutely and i do agree with you i
think it is sensible and dramatic i just
wonder whether on this income
target then i wonder whether we're
better off sort of reviewing that
decision
for the next year's budget instead of
this year's budget i don't know if
that's worth it
i know that we sort of don't want to set
ourselves up to be unrealistic and we're
cautious that there's lots of time here
um to fill elizabeth do you want to come
in yeah um
i think we could have a further
discussion with this when i present the
uh the paper later on in part two of the
uh
agenda um because i refer to this point
as well
thank you okay all right thanks
elizabeth okay well i think there's
there's a mix
of things there um i just post from a
member perspective whether we're
comfortable
changing this target as it happens for
this year knowing that next year is
going to be difficult or whether we we
sort of push that to next year for
review
um i don't know what people's views are
on that whether we take this now or
later
i think we've there's a broad argument
either way for me there's
there's a probably a pragmatic solution
to this which is
uh we could have a stretch target that
we're aiming at
um over and above the actual
target we're looking so we we know what
we're looking for as a minimum
and we may well look for a stretch
target if that's achievable
okay so a range is probably what i would
look at
thank you council mcgee rain's looking
puzzled
councillor ross did you know i just say
i i agree with definitely that's a
good suggestion okay um i know that it's
referred to anyway as you say
uh in the budget report elizabeth so i
think it's probably worth us just having
a look i think from a member perspective
our view is
is kind of coming to terms on that you
know we we probably keep with the
the existing budget that we've got let's
say this is sorry 150k but that we
we aim for as cancer mcgee has a sort of
stretch target
this year and see how we get on instead
of changing the sort of official
income target for the year um i think
that sounds like
as you say a pragmatic solution halfway
um
lorraine do you want to come in on that
just cautious that you look
yeah i'm just sort of thinking how to
how to present it really i mean we've
obviously spoken to
to board on this at length um as you can
imagine
and what we have to do each year is
obviously look at the whole income and
expenditure of star
and and how challenging um you know both
sides of income and expenditure can be
because
um year on year you know the start and
fee from partners doesn't get inflated
and so that adds an additional burden
because
we absorb costs such as um staffing
increments that can be 50 60 70 000 a
year
just because of people's natural
progression of the pay grade so
um i think there's sort of a i'll say a
double whammy here but i'm meaning that
positively that that we the income
doesn't increase and the challenge for
expenditure
and sorry about the wrong way around the
expenditure um
increases and then we've obviously got
the challenge to bring income in to
balance the books
but for me personally i am actually um
comfortable with what we've proposed
today in terms of
um the target that we've presented to
you
and obviously this is joint committee's
decision not my but i just want to
express that i am very comfortable with
the way that we've presented that
and apologies that there's a little bit
more information to follow in the um
private paper later um it's just the
commercial side of star but obviously we
wouldn't put into a public meeting
so i hope that just gives some clarity
well that does yeah i think um
on that basis then i think i'm
comfortable with the proposal in there i
could see nods
yep i think um you know i think you
probably
i should say aspirational lorraine as
ever so that's
absolutely fine by us um so i think i'm
seeing agreement for that paper so i
would
castle mcgee did you want us to come in
fc microphones come on uh well i was
just thinking that's a get out of a jail
card that you didn't use so that's fine
thank you for that uh lorraine noted
right so we are comfortable with
item four yes thank you
continuous improvement update
this is um a double act with um myself
and elizabeth
um i'm just gonna start off so this
report just gives you an
update on some of our um continuous
improvements that we've done to date and
plans for the future as well
i'm just going to start with a couple of
good news stories
um in terms of awards we won the
national social value award
for embedding social value into
procurement which was presented
at the national conference and we're
also finalists for the i network awards
under three categories
the connected procurement and commission
category the covid response
and the most innovative video which i
think you've all um seen
a copy of our diy video that we
presented
we have also nominated our people team
for
a epic team award with traffic council
and for all the work that they did
around brexit border closures
testing centres and ppe procurements at
the end of
last year and beginning of this year
we have also been undertaking a number
of recruitment
exercises over the last few months to
fill some vacancies
um this is where we've had staff that
have moved to new opportunities
elsewhere or to focus on their new
business ventures this has resulted
in um promotions for five internal staff
which
shows that our grow your own policy is
working and is helping us to retain some
excellent members of the team
so just for example we had um one member
of staff who joined us as an apprentice
he was promoted to trainee and is now a
procurement officer
and studying for his qualifications
procurement is a difficult field to
recruit from
um so it's good that we started we still
get quite a lot of external interest in
some of our roles as well
just also to flag that one team member
has utilized the trafford voluntary
redundancy scheme
um and we'll be reducing the staffing
structure to make that saving
over time moving on we've
also achieved the sips corporate ethics
mark for the third contin
consecutive year and this is about the
work that we do around modern slavery
and about ethical procurement as well
and also i think from comments at the
last joint committee we just wanted to
update you on the staff well-being
um we have continued to work hard to
support our staff of their physical
and mental well-being we do weekly
updates and reminders about well-being
we've set up some staff groups such as
the parents group a book club
and the step challenge we now have more
regular and full
team meetings as well and leadership
team have
undertaken welfare calls to all staff
just to have a check on how they are
doing
as well as providing details to the
traffic initiatives and support
we have had one member of staff who has
been off with covered and
suffered quite quite badly with it but
i'm pleased to say she's
on a phased return to work now and is
um making a good recovery
so moving on then to um the specific
work that we've been doing
as you'll have seen um we finalized the
business plan and launched that earlier
this year
um we are now doing some blogs and some
work to promote
the business plan so for example we went
to a ten sides
assistant directors group yesterday to
talk them through the business plan and
what we were doing for team side as well
as we've talked about we are looking at
our income plan for
21.22 um and
as we've talked about it has been
difficult in year
but we have got a number of
opportunities in the pipeline and we'll
be continuing to develop that and to bid
for work as well
intend is the contract management system
and implementation of that is well
underway
and it's divided into two stages and the
first stage is about uploading the
contracts registering all the data from
the hundreds of contracts that we have
across star
so that's now progressing well and once
that's completed
then the star councils can then think
about how they want
to use that system for their in-house
contract management functions
the 10-point plan um has been in place
for nine months and that was what we
were shortlisted for for the i
network awards as part of our continuous
improvement ethos that plan is now
embedded as usual
as embedded as business as usual and the
data on that has currently been collated
just to show the impact it's had but
it's i think the plan is done it's now
embedded
then we've also been looking at web
forms on our website so the use of
online forms for some of our
documentation which allows us to
log and track it so this is internal
documentation
um with our partner councils we've also
been looking at our web contents to
ensure it
is compliant with the accessibility
requirements
and looking at a new design work which
is being developed with
traffic council for a new website
we have now included a blog facility on
our website as well so we
are starting to populate that as well
then we have our ethics modern slave and
responsible procurement as i said we've
got the corporate ethics mark but we do
do
a continuous review of the responsible
procurement strategy to reflect any new
updates and requirements from partners
and our e-learning package has now been
updated to include elements about modern
slavery
as well the e-learning
package itself um has been updated to
make it a bit more user-friendly
and we'll be doing some further updates
and roll out of that to
partners as we go forward
so i'm going to pause to take a breath
and i think hand over to elizabeth
thank you nicola um yeah so i'll take
you through the
the continuous improvement um for the
delivery team
uh social value top of the list um so
our star social value action plan is
well underway
and a number of significant milestones
um have been
uh completed um the action plan will be
supported by the start
social value strategy which we are
currently drafting
and we've got a session uh next month
with the whole of the
wider leadership team within star um to
make sure that that things um which we
will share
um it will incorporate the six themes
from the gm social value framework
any corporate priorities policies
strategies
and commitments from our councils and
obviously the
carbon neutral um 2038 um challenge
um the strategy we call it strategy
policy charter because
we get all sorts of names across our
four partners
um it can be used in-house for you guys
as well um and then
i think i mentioned this last time
around the social value mapping
um so we've mapped the council
priorities for
for the four councils um with the the gm
policy
and um the start of the tom's measures
um so that's ready and um we will be
working with teams within the the four
authorities to get that out
and it will inform our toms 21-22
there's been a slight change from the
task force on the on the toms measures
for 21.22
and so we're just looking how we
incorporate those would you
move down a bit nicola thank you uh
social value organization i think
again i mentioned this last time it's a
pilot that we're working with trafford
on so it has commenced um and a report
was presented to trafford clt
uh during this month and there's an
action plan on the back of that
and we are working with trafford team to
to get that rolled out
um including a steering group that
has been is about to be set up sorry uh
the south carolina value maturity index
exercise
um has been done for trafford and we're
now in the process of rolling that out
for
stockport rochdale and typesite um
dropped in there just a reminder that we
have a you know a plethora of social
value case studies we we get
obvious as you can see from our quarter
three data we get some
excellent social value through our bids
um and there's some really good
um case studies on there and there's a
couple due to go in there that we've uh
secured this quarter quarter four um
that will go on there so just a link
in there to alert you to those social
value strategies
um we presented as nicola said at the
notion of national social value
conference
we chaired a panel discussion around
awesome case studies
so we had representatives from trafford
and rochdale and the star team on that
um
conference and it went down really
really really well um
we're also attending and supporting a
group of representatives
um across the partners and this is for
the social economy and community
wealth building um so that that's
happening in pockets around the councils
we're supporting that but then we want
to bring it through um
to our social value strategy as well so
more to come on that
just an update on oxygen last time i
said we had one little bit that we
needed to
to finalize we finally sorted that out
so the evaluation model
um is now agreed across rochdale and
um stockport and tameside um
and just to note that rochdale and
stockport have had their first sign ups
via the procurement process
after relaunching the oxygen program
last november
commercial contract management so we
have now appointed and this is one of
the promotions that nicola was talking
about earlier we've
appointed a senior project manager on a
12-month basis
internally so it's lewis and carla who
is currently our category manager for
adults
um he's going to be looking at the
high-value contracts that are already in
place across the
four councils to see where we can do
some negotiation and hopefully make
some some savings there um he's we're
just waiting to backfill him as soon as
he's backfilled he will be starting
probably um early april and so we can
bring an action plan
next time on the forecasted savings
there
um new procurement regulations as you
are all aware green paper was issued by
the
cabinet office just before christmas
last year um we have done a collective
response to that
with gmca we have um
canvassed some of our colleagues within
our partners to get their views and
ideas and obviously put our
views and ideas forward as well um there
are there are implications in terms of
the integrated care
system um that has been the white paper
that was issued at november
time so we're working with colleagues
within your um councils just to
see how that will play out and how that
will work in terms of procurement and
the green paper
so again more to come on that as and
when we have the information
brexit um so the new regulations are
advertised on uh
that came into play on the first of
january uh we had
a seamless transition really into the
new um
arrangements um we continue to work with
you
your services on brexit planning and
our documents are we're updated and um
we we haven't seen any issues um
we had you know a few hairy moments uh
just before christmas because of
all the uh the issues in terms of
catering we thought
you know schools weren't gonna get their
food come at the beginning of january
for the children but the school's closed
so we had a lot of work to do on that
but then it
you know it wasn't required in the end
um so we continue to to monitor the
situation
and uh for high-risk contracts and we'll
alert anything that we need to
okay um recommendations nicola
please consider and comment on this
report really
um today and our future plans thank you
thank you both very much that's great
lots to talk about in there i think
um brexit remember that
but no really interesting report thank
you both very much
have we any comments questions counselor
ross
okay yeah just to to mention that the
brexit piece because it is so easily
forgotten but the amount of work that
you would have had to done
and it seems like a long time ago now
where you know we're having major issues
just before christmas so you know what
well done on that and also well doing on
the grow your own strategy which is
great to see in any organization and i
know that staff
treats it with the importance it
deserves i'm just out of interest in
terms of
external uh positions that you advertise
very interesting what kind of demand are
you getting um for positions you do
advertise and is there a
where about so you know people applying
from um appreciate the jobs market is um
there's quite a few people that will be
in the jobs market at the moment so any
information on that would be uh would be
helpful thank you
thank you elizabeth yeah check if i i
don't mind responding on that so
um we advertised two tpo so that's the
trainee
um trainee role and we've got 65
applications
and they were mainly from um we
advertising the colleges
and universities and and in the main
those applications came
from from there um as we get further up
the um the careers so the the pos and
the
category managers were more difficult
and we didn't get as many
um applications and also um the caliber
of those applications so they weren't
really in the
um procurement and you know they hadn't
come from procurement roles
so we would struggle to appoint them um
just because we need them to
to hit the ground running um we tried
something this time and we advertised in
sips magazine for the category manager
roles
but still didn't see um the a
large number of applications through
that so this is where
the grow your own policy is really
really important so we
we need to make sure that we're
investing in our team
keeping that retention so that we get
them ready to move up to the next step
as and when these opportunities arise
thank you thanks elizabeth any more
comments questions
nope okay thank you very much uh for the
continuous improvement update
uh i think we've all noted that and and
we accept that as a committee thank you
very much
um urgent business i've not been
notified of any
um i don't think we've got any on the
agenda have we fabiola
no we don't chair okay thank you um the
date and time the next meeting
is um is listed on the agenda
and we've got a suggestion for um the
arrangements for the next meeting we're
happy to
happy with those yep seeing nods
okay um before we finish the meeting
i've got an exclusion
revolution revolution resolution motion
crikey uh to uh to uh
to ask members of the public uh who
might be watching to
to um to stop the live feed so we can
continue to talk about some private
business so
are we comfortable that the public are
excluded from this meeting consideration
for the remaining items on the agenda
because the likelihood of disclosure of
exempt information which falls in one of
the more descriptive categories
or categories in the local government
acts 1972 schedule 12a
agree say it without reading it thank
you